bedtime will forever be my favourite time of the day
but I still have a few more things to get
through before I can finally say
that's enough todaying for today
and after what's already been quite a long day
I gave my husband a look that said
tag you're it
and took myself off to an evening yoga class
and normally by the time I make it to class
it's already dark but tonight it was still light out
which means summer is on its way
and that just makes my little soul so happy
cause I don't know about you
but I'm ready to shake off the winter blues
and soak up some D
vitamin d of course
my husband made the kids some spaghetti Bolognese while I was out
but because I'm just so delusionally ready for some warmer weather
I'm gonna eat like it's already here
and all day I've been craving a really big chicken salad
so that's what we're having
But if you were to ask me where I was at mentally
I'm deep in a court of silver flames
and I'm just counting down the minutes before I can read it
although I won't lie I was close to crying with joy tasting this
because it was everything I needed it to be
And so much more
I need to know who else can't go to bed without cleaning up first
because no matter how tired I am
I will always force myself
to do a quick whip around the house before I stop for the day
I find I wake up in a much better head space
and feel like I'm gonna be more productive
if my house is at least a little bit reset
I can't do any vacuuming cause mark’s in the other room
tryna get the kids to sleep
and also… I don't really want to
I'm powering through this last part
but the end is in sight
but one thing I would take every night without fail
is my HeadRest from BraveFace
because honestly if I don't
I am tossing and turning and overthinking all night
They use chamomile and passionflower
for the perfect combination to help me get to sleep
and stay asleep
and I've been taking it for almost two years
and I genuinely swear by it